one of your names at least in this space
and time is c like the letter c and and
you told me that
c means a lot of things it's the speed
of light it's the render rate of the
universe it's yes in spanish it's the
crescent moon
and it happens to be my favorite
programming language
because it's uh it basically runs the
world but it's also
powerful fast and it's dangerous because
you can mess things up really bad with
it because of all the pointers but
anyway which of these associations uh
with the name c is the coolest to you
i mean to me the coolest is the speed of
light obviously or the speed of light
when i say render rate of the universe i
think i mean the speed of light
because essentially that's
what we're rendering at see i think
we'll know
if we're in a simulation if the speed of
light changes because if they can
improve their render speed then
what's already pretty good it's already
pretty good but if it improves
then
we'll know you know we can probably be
like okay they've updated or upgraded
it's fast enough for us humans because
it seems
like uh
it seems immediate there's no delay
there's no latency in terms of like us
humans on earth interacting with things
but if you're like uh
like intergalactic species operating on
a much larger scale then you're gonna
start noticing some weird stuff or if
you can operate
in like around a black hole then you're
gonna start to see some render issues
you can't go faster than the speed of
light correct
so it really limits our ability or and
it's one's ability to travel space
theoretically you can you have wormholes
so i there's nothing in general
relativity
that uh precludes faster than
uh
speed of light travel but it just seems
you're gonna have to do some really
funky stuff with uh
very heavy things that have like
weirdnesses that have basically tears in
space time we don't know how to do that
dune navigators know how to do it
do navigators yeah yeah folding space
basically making wormholes
so
the name c yes
who are you
are you do you think of yourself as
multiple people are you one person do
you know
like in this morning were you a
different person than you are tonight we
are i should say recording this
basically at midnight which is awesome
yes thank you so much
i think i'm about eight hours late no
you're right on time good morning this
is the beginning of a new day soon
anyway uh are you the same person you
were in the morning in the evening
do you you're you're is there multiple
people in there do you think of yourself
as one person or maybe you have no clue
are you just a giant mystery to yourself
okay these are really intense questions
but uh
let's go because i asked this myself
like look in the mirror who are you
people tell you to just be yourself but
what does that even mean uh i mean i
think my personality changes with
everyone i talk to
so i'm a very inconsistent personality
yeah person to person so the interaction
your personality
materializes
like i'll go from being like a
megalomaniac to being like
you know just like a total
hermit who is very shy so some
combinatorial com combination of your
mood and the person you're interacting
with yeah moon people i'm interacting
with but i think everyone's like that
maybe not
well not everybody acknowledges it and
able to introspect it who brings that
what kind of person what kind of mood
brings out the best in you
as an artist and as a human
can you introspect this like my best
friends like like people i can
when i'm like
super confident and i know that they're
gonna understand
understand everything i'm saying so like
my best friends then
when i can start being really funny
that's always my like peak mode but it's
like yeah takes a lot to get there
you